y hablamos de economía en directo
américa de france 24 ya está conmigo en
el estudio daniel hablando onda ni
bienvenida hoy a jueves casi finalizando
la semana sí señor hablemos entonces
danny el precio del petróleo que vuelve
a subir después de un pequeño respiro
bueno todos sabemos que desde que inició
la guerra pues los precios han venido
subiendo por el temor a que rusia que es
uno de los principales productores y
exportadores pues deje de suministrarlo
pues resulta que el miércoles el barril
de brent se desplomó en más del 13 por
ciento como hace mucho tiempo no lo
hacía después de que el embajador de
emiratos árabes unidos en washington
insinuar a que sus socios de la opep que
es el grupo de mayores exportadores pues
podría aumentar la oferta pero horas
después el ministro de energía de ese
mismo país salió a contradecirlo y
afirmó que están muy comprometidos con
lo que se ha acordado al interior de la
opep más que es el mismo grupo de
exportadores más rusia y otros aliados y
porque entonces van los precios suben en
este momento tal recordemos que a medida
que haya más barriles en circulación en
el mundo los precios bajan porque hay
más oferta y este gremio de exportadores
no aquí abrir el grifo como le ha pedido
a eeuu porque en parte le conviene que
los precios estén altos ayer entonces
con esas declaraciones o ayer y hoy
mejor los precios se han movido al ritmo
de estas declaraciones de emiratos
árabes unidos- y como al parecer no
habrá más oferta por la cotización está
subiendo alrededor de un 5 por ciento
la gente lanza números como 200 dólares
por barril pero aquí estamos en un
territorio desconocido no hemos visto
una interrupción potencial de esta
escala desde la crisis del petróleo de
la década de 1970 y de alguna manera
esto es aún más grave entonces qué tan
alto podrían subir los precios depende
por supuesto de qué tipo de interrupción
tendremos y qué medidas de emergencia
simplemente para contrarrestarla
danny y reino unido- sancionó a más
oligarcas rusos en medio de esta guerra
concretamente
congeló los activos de siete de ellos y
los acusó de haberse beneficiado
financieramente de sus lazos con el
presidente ruso vladimir putin uno ayush
es el multimillonario roman abramovich
quien es el dueño del británico chelsea
fc quien lo sacó a la venta tras el
inicio de la guerra en ucrania y quien
tiene una fortuna estimada de más de 12
mil millones de dólares el gobierno
británico suspendió no solamente esta
venta sino cualquier transacción del
club incluyendo la comercialización de
sus productos y de sus boletas detalles
los vamos a tener en la crónica de
deportes mientras tanto le cuento que
entre los sancionados también figuran
oleg deripaska quien tiene
participaciones en el grupo en más y
andrei kostin quien es presidente del
bcv que es el segundo banco más grande
de rusia también está igor sechín en
consejero delegado de la empresa rosneft
y el director ejecutivo de gazprom la
empresa de gas rusa entró ayer hablamos
de mcdonald's start box nestlé kfc pero
ya se sumaron más empresas que operan en
rusia que dejan de funcionar dan y claro
que si raúl pues ayer fue la comida
entonces hoy son los videojuegos
hay gente que no puede vivir con esto y
también para traerse es una manera de
distraerse sobre todo los adolescentes
claro y que las sanciones van dirigidas
contra las personas en rusia se trata de
las japonesas sony y nintendo la primera
dijo que se une al llamado de la
comunidad global a la paz en ucrania y
por eso suspende todos los envíos de
software y de hardware el lanzamiento de
gran turismo 7 y las operaciones de la
tienda de playstation en rusia de hecho
los equipos rusos y también la selección
rusa ya no están disponibles en el juego
fifa mientras que su competidor nintendo
aseguró que se van a vender las
existencias que tiene pero se suspenden
las exportaciones por cuestiones
logísticas tanto de envíos como del
procesamiento de pagos en rublo en
rublos y se suman entonces estas
compañías a otras de videojuegos como
xbox activision blizzard o epic games
que han extendido la medida también
hable a bielorrusia
y el kremlin pues dice que su economía
está en shock por cuenta de todo este
éxodo masivo y que hay una guerra
económica por parte de eeuu
danny la solidaridad con ucrania
mantiene los pedidos a tope en una
fábrica de banderas esto en francia mire
pues en burdeos que quedaba en el
suroeste de francia y una empresa que
fabrica banderas desde hace un siglo y
está asegurando que han tenido que
contratar a otros empleados para cumplir
con la altísima demanda de autoridades
locales y de particulares para comprar
banderas ucranianas la demanda coincide
con un periodo justamente de gran
producción debido a la campaña electoral
en francia danny entonces gracias a por
toda esta información de economía nos
vemos más adelante con más pasamos a
hablar ahora con más romeros salen
análisis